hello I'm Xena but are we welcome to the
concert hall here in Stockholm where
this year's Nobel laureates receive
their awards from His Majesty the King
of Sweden for their outstanding
contributions to literature economics
and science this is the first time that
they have been brought together in
discussion on television and we're also
joined in the audience by some of their
family and friends who traveled here to
be with them as well as students from
Sweden welcome to this year's noble
minds
[Music]
Nobel laureates welcome to you all
and congratulations
you'll want your Nobel Prizes because
you know you are these very rational
logical beings or you have great clarity
of thought in your novels and in your
economic work and so on so do you really
act very rationally with great logic in
your personal lives generally you're not
eating which is Hendersons so yes you
obviously do
yes I 100 percent rational but very very
occasionally we have to step outside
that circle so the one little memory I
have is a new piece of equipment that
was being developed we only had access
to it before 8 a.m.
come in very early to try and use it I
couldn't get it to work I tried
everything unplugged this I'm pleased
that eventually I said I'll just have to
go home but I had one final thing give
it a kick sprang into life and there was
a loose wire so all right well let's
just see you I'm gonna go round the
table you know and just get a quick quip
from all of you the Iraqi friend I was
in an earthquake in Pasadena in 1970 it
happened at 6 o'clock I was asleep I
went immediately jump out of the bed and
went to the to the toilet and flush the
toilet immediately as a kind of reflex
actually it's a reflex we weren't active
O'Shea the third of the chemistry you
know the word falsification rationality
of a scientific when you have a good
idea you have to prove that it is wrong
until you have tried everything and then
you have proven the idea but I'm very
unwell I try to show that my ID is right
I push a bit too far okay Kip Thorne one
of the physics laureates my greatest
insights come in the middle of the night
and I'm sound asleep it's not rational I
don't know how it happens but my mind
somehow irrationally throw those things
together I go write down notes in the
bathroom wake up the next morning
and believe it or not a third of the
time it's good it's good I have no idea
where I came from that sounds yeah
serendipity I guess yeah rave ice you
ever done anything completely amazing a
lot of irrational things I think the
most important one was I fell in love at
19 went chasing a woman the Chicago and
it was the end of me I flunked out and
then I eventually got back into that
mighty yes back there might I flunked
out of MIT and back after that I came
and I got a job and that job made my
career mm-hmm the education wasn't worth
a damn
oh well we'll come back on to that kind
of theme later very parish another of
the physics laureates I became a
physicist and shuttle the irrational way
was to decide not to be a chemist not to
be an engineer not to be a writer the
last left was my freshman physics class
Richard I'm gonna jump leave you out
just for a moment so I can come to you
because we're gonna talk about your
economic theory but the medicine
laureates might young well so choosing
to be a scientist is I won't say it's
irrational but it does come with a lot
of risk and I got lots of advice from
people that were close to me when am I
going to get a job when are you going to
choose something that it's
understandable to the outside word world
that has a simple track forward that you
can be sure to support yourself and such
in such a way so there is a very there's
a very important component there's an
emotional component in choosing to take
risks and become a scientist mmm Michael
Ross fascism so so I would say in in
order and having a self-destructive
temper as a young person it's not very
rational being a sports fan is not very
rational and and then the concept of
risk-taking is actually has a deep
biological basis but of course people
like taking risks and and that has an
upside of course as Mike mentioned but
it's also it also can be destructive you
seem very benign now you've lost the
term
have you the self-destructive tenant I'm
most of the time under control we're at
progress Jeffrey had work at RIT work in
progress but if I handsome fellow to my
right and I work together his name
escapes me we we came up a number of
times with labored pieces of poor aisle
public behavior we thought our stunts
were hilarious I'm not sure that
everybody else and our mitts did do but
we couldn't help herself all right okay
well Cassie we should grow our
literature laureate they've never done
anything I'm completely crazy that you
not crazy but I guess my wife and I we
have a large collection of soft toys
which we pretend still belong to our
daughter the 25 we have voices for them
all and they have whole kind of personal
histories and relationships between them
have histories I guess that's verging on
the irrational perhaps but I think it's
perfectly reasonable all right okay well
I brought up this Odyssey of irrational
versus rational behavior because you
rich the sailor won the Nobel Prize for
your work in behavioral economics which
really says that you know mainstream
economics didn't get it right that
people individuals households don't act
in a rational way when it comes to
taking economic decisions or indeed any
other kind of decision so just explain
to us give us an overview of what
behavioral economics actually is well
behavioral economics is sort of just
doing economics that would accommodate
all of the stories that we've just heard
it was triggered by a dinner party were
and a bowl of cashew nuts wasn't it oh
well yes I removed
a bowl of cashew nuts that it was a dick
ting dinner party and after I came back
everyone thanked me for removing these
bowl of cashew nuts but then since it
was a group of economists we began to
wonder how it was that we could be happy
since an axiom of economics is more
choices are always better than less so
yeah that was my Apple thank you for
removing the bowl of cashew because they
didn't want to eat anymore
and they had plenty more colored if the
ball were there they would have
continued and Richard I mean a lot of
people have focused on just one
component of your work which is this
concept of lunch and you wrote a book of
course with Cass Sunstein coordinate and
it's about how people can be nudged into
making better decisions and David
Cameron former British prime minister
set up a nudge unit and indeed many many
other countries followed suit so just
give us an idea how does not actually
work what does it try to set out to do
well nudge takes into consideration what
our biases are and then tries to
introduce small features of the
environment that will adjust them so for
example suppose we're worried that this
show might run over then fortunately I
set my phone for the amount of time
we're supposed to do so when it starts
beeping we'll note and and we won't
worry about the risk of running over so
that's the I mean there's some people
thank you I get the message
you've advised governments on nudging
you know trying to get policies that for
instance will get young people like the
students we've got here in the audience
just save up for their old-age pensions
and to try to get people to take
decisions which are in their
self-interest based on the fact that
people don't always do so but can we
really leave it to politicians and
policy makers and their advisors such as
yourself to really nudge a person into
into doing something like that mean
isn't it manipulation in some ways well
the the real point is that we have no
choice so there's no alternative to
nudging the only alternative is bad
magic
gentlemen I mean what do you think about
behavioral economics and in particular
this aspect of it which is you know the
concept of nudge would some of you like
to be nudged or have been nudged into
doing something that avoided reckless
behavior yeah I want to know if the
society and there's something different
I wonder how you think about this I mean
we teach the wrong kind of math to our
kids yeah oh you agree with that I mean
for example I mean if you want to nudge
me or into a certain thing I'd like to
know the odds right and we don't know
how to make art in high school or grade
school I would teach it by having them
gamble Yeah right so that what people
know deadly serious what you want a
nation of gamblers nuts not no no you
see yeah there are you jump too fast
yeah I don't do that okay no no the idea
was used as a mechanism to learn the
mathematics and the thinking that goes
with probabilistic reasoning right Jeff
Hall you are one of the three laureates
for the prize in medicine or physiology
and talking about as I say you know the
psychological aspects of economics and
in behavioral economics and how the mind
works and the impact it might have on
economics but you you won your prize for
what makes the body tick our body clock
Jeff why don't you just
perhaps spell out for us what we mean by
our body clock there are many kinds of
revealed daily rhythms that can be
observed and measured
rhythms but there's long-standing
information from studying a whole
variety of different kinds of organisms
that these revealed rhythms are
underpinned by biological clocks Michael
Ross fashion and Mike Young through your
research on on fruit flies we discovered
that we have these body clocks you know
we humors as well as all other animals
and you've you discover that by our
isolating genes in in fruit flies in
fact I think the fruit fly is featured
in so many Nobel Prize experiments it
deserves its own little little Nobel
Prize wouldn't you say a little prize
see the little thing yes Mike Young once
you discover the components of these
clocks you can look for them all over
the organism and as Jeff and his
colleagues showed in Drosophila you find
different parts of the earth the fruit
fly the fruit fly you've got you've got
many different body parts that display
these rhythms using these clocks so it's
not just behavior it's many aspects of
physiology the the other thing that
became clear was that you could start
with the genes that we found in the
fruit fly and lo and behold you have
relatives in all the other members of
the animal kingdom including us so can
we ask questions that would help
shiftwork because you know people who
work in the emergency services deal
better with the kind of work that they
have to do at night can it help us
understand why babies don't sleep during
the night I mean I always find that
expression
oh I sleep so well just like a baby must
have been said by somebody who's never
looked after a baby because we know they
don't sleep at night right so I mean you
know does your work help us understand
these common experiences well in many
cases what it reveals is there's much
more complexity to what's wrong or what
we think we're observing when a baby's
not sleeping for example or take jetlag
when we go from New York or Boston to
at the Stockholm what's really going on
most of us think well in a few days my
one body clock will get to Stockholm and
until then I'm going to be in a state of
malaise in fact what happens is that
since you have clocks all over your body
there is disagreement that starts
occurring between the cells in different
parts of your body about what time of
day it is and so in fact at the end of a
flight from New York to Stockholm for
the next few days you really occupy it
your body is occupying multiple time
zones simultaneously depending on which
clock you look at you think that there's
good and bad times during the day where
are we right now
[Laughter]
so it depends it depends what that
there's there's times in which which are
more favourable for some things than
others yeah so I think what you're
alluding to perhaps is that this is a
very successful nap time for example for
example for example especially for a
gentleman or ladies are aged around
around this table where in fact who were
up late last night were up very late
that was when you received your period
all the festivities and so on construe
an astronaut that has no resetting
mechanism also dude aren't the cabins my
impression was that the the cabins have
very intense like artificial like dark
cycles to mimic to mimic the external
pretty primitive suicide if they didn't
yeah even if they didn't if they were in
constant darkness they would show these
rhythms and and that's and in fact
that's how they were originally revealed
in these models people often have a
reality is that if you put an organism
into cycles that are different from a
day like 7 hours 7 hours that certain
organisms depending on the organism can
synchronize yeah that's the occult
cycles but at some point you're so far
away from 24 when you do these tests
they snap
we know here in Sweden actually lot of
people do say they have these lights
that lamps that mimic daylight don't
they because I have such a dark days but
this time of year but some of your
colleagues working on the body clock
have benefited from the work of our
chemistry laureates because of course
gentlemen you won your award for
developing a technique called cryo e/m
which for the first time captured images
of molecules that were not visible using
standard techniques and of course we
know that the world of molecules is is
the core of what we call life so Richard
Anderson in a nutshell what is cryo a.m.
I think our our area of interest and
expertise is the easiest to explain in
this group
we basically freeze a thin film of the
molecules of life take a picture of it
and then you look at the picture with
your eyes it's magnified and you can see
all the molecules the computer helps you
to interpret what they are but the
methodologies are the tools that were
invented by the others particularly
Jacques Du Bois she mm-hmm alright well
we'll go to shank to Basho then so this
tool that enables you to look at these
molecules I mean its potential its
possibilities of how it can help human
endeavor cure illnesses we are
physicists we worked in biology and we
get the Nobel Prize in Chemistry
don't confuse people please because
because we see atoms with the help of
those people and when we see atoms with
do chemistry and chemistry is a very
powerful science because if you have a
biological object you see how the atoms
are interacting one with the other you
see how alzheimer filaments are attached
to each other perhaps you see a drug
which will separate them or will prevent
them to associate use
anything with with with chemistry
it's an extraordinary powerful method
but I mean in the case of you know what
you want your prize for for instance in
the case of the Zika virus cryo PM was
used to generate 3d images of the virus
which meant researchers could try to
work out you know what kind of drugs
would help to resist the virus for
instance I don't know if you want to
pick that up you are in fact the Zika
virus is a perfect illustration for the
dis combined technology that is now
available so when we do know the
structure of it now it doesn't mean that
we immediately find a way of combating
it seized but but it makes it possible
you know so they potentially Richard
Saylor yeah I was just gonna say that
this links up to the conversation we
were having a bit earlier which is
whether choice architecture or nudging
is good or bad it just depends on who's
using it so all the scientists here have
created knowledge that can be used for
good or evil this the same is true for
behavioral science or behavioral
economics and many companies nudge for
evil the last last night my toast was to
nudge for good and but that's a hope
Richard Henderson I mean all of you have
worked you know for many many years on
your endeavors and I think it was one
chemist who said you know miracles
sometimes occur but you have to work
terribly hard I mean it's part and
parcel of everything you do isn't it
failure is part and parcel of that that
you'll carry out lots and lots of
experiments and expect many of them not
to succeed yeah I think we are aiming to
find out completely new things so if
when you're thinking of an experiment in
any area if the the choice that you make
is close to the knowledge that you have
already then you're likely to have a
successful experiment but you won't have
learned very much so if you make a
bigger jump take a
bigger risk and then most of the time
the experiments would have failed but
when it succeeds you make a bigger jump
forward so I learned from Fred Sanger
who had was had two Nobel Prizes for his
work in sequencing protein and DNA he
used to say that you should aim for a
very high failure rate my interpretation
was ninety-nine percent failure rate but
the one percent that succeed takes you
with a very big step forward which is
worth all the effort you've spent on the
other night I would say that leaves out
one one important component especially
for young people who who like science
and that is the discussion of high risk
high failure or very lofty goals leaves
out an element of craftsmanship to our
profession in other words I think I
think that the thing with you the chance
of of having tremendous success is is
very small for any one individuals we
are the we are the progeny we are the
beneficiaries of also a lot of luck as
well as hard work and perhaps a tiny
little bit of talent but the the fact is
that most of us here love what we did
hmm and so that carries you through
failures sure and you have to really
like to do experiment interesting micro
smash because when you were young you
were marked out as a potential failure
at school you were very unruly by your
own admission and you've known each
other I know for many many years for 30
years but you also attractive I'll show
you know you say that you would just
select sick at school and rich sailor
you were mildly dyslexic I mean I think
it's interesting that your path to this
success is now worrying about the wrong
thing it has been you know but it's just
inspiring to people isn't it listen
listen to Michael he said something very
profound and that is people like to work
on things that are fun that are a
pleasure to work on that's absolutely
fundamental none of us at least I
certainly in my life didn't think I'm
gonna win the Nobel Prize it was never
in my mind it was not my life was not
dedicated to winning a prize
my life was dedicated I enjoyed this
thing I was working on it was fun I have
my buddies with me we had a great time
the whole project the LIGO project isn't
based on the fact that the oh god we
fail we just listen to me
yeah I gotta listen to me this is
important because that destruction that
ye said it right and asking Oh Oh God
failure failure failure that's not the
way you think ya know the consequence is
that you do things which you get a kick
out of
and luckily sometimes they turn out to
be important sure but just going back
[Applause]
that brings me to UM Kazu issue guru
universally known as ish who won the
Nobel Prize for Literature and I know
that in your writing career you've had
some four starts and works that you've
discarded and started all over again but
you know you are now amongst the the
Giants of the world of literature you've
written eight novels and so a lot of
your your novels seem on the surface to
be quite different you know set in
different countries and so on but there
does seem to be a common theme the
relationship between the present and the
past would you say yes I mean the
surface of my novels are kind of
deceptive people think I keep moving on
truth is I keep writing the same thing
over and over again obsessively
and people don't realize it because they
have very different settings but I think
I perhaps there is a parallel but see
what the kind of way I make progress in
the kind of way that the guys around
this table have done I around some sort
of piece of ground sometimes if somebody
comes up with an idea or a topic that's
somewhere out there and I think would
that be great for somebody else but it's
not on this little thing I'm I'm closing
in on I'm digging away in the dead of
night you know looking expecting to sort
of uncover something strange down there
you mentioned the scientists around the
table but you are interested in
a discussion about science and one of
your most famous books never let me go
looks at scientific advances in a world
that's kind of gone mad perhaps setting
in in the future where society expects
that all illnesses can be fixed and they
don't want to turn the clock back to you
know people dying of cancer and so on is
that something that really concerns you
the misuse of science these are very
important things I think for books films
plays to address but that isn't
essentially what literature is for you
know it doesn't have to directly address
these questions I think what literature
does is allow us to understand each
other across cultural barriers
linguistic barriers so that when we come
to have the debate about how we order
our society what is important we
understand how other people not
obviously like us feel most discoveries
I think are two edged blades and this is
at the heart of the Nobel metaphor if
you like a man who invents dynamite
which can do great things and very
destructive things we have to have a
debate in society we have to think about
what we do with the great breakthroughs
massage surrounds ability the other way
to make sure that what we do is
understood enough by the public it
doesn't have to be exactly what we
measure
you know this famous problem was the CP
snow made such a fuss over and I think
he had did a lot of damage with that is
there this cross-fertilization of people
who do science people who do music
people who do arts that's got to go and
it isn't that I mean I'd like to have
for example if in our country right now
I'd like to have the arts be able to
know a little more science very bearish
I know you're a great fan of Kazuo
Ishiguro's work what do you think about
this conversation between science and
art you wanted to be a novelist didn't
you yeah I'm
and I think what I'm as I said I
eliminated several professions and ended
up in physics the earliest one was being
a writer because I read all the time
when I was a kid if you write a novel on
a threat by a hundred thousand readers
you're really writing a hundred thousand
novels that's why there's book clubs
because it's not that anybody the guy
next to you doesn't read well it's that
how that novel that's interpreted by
them is different than how you interpret
the novel so it's a fantastic thing that
you can write something that actually is
a hundred thousand stories I think and
why the movies never as good as the book
because the movie does too much it
doesn't really have the same partnership
that's my view did you like the movie of
your book never let me go yes and I
loved the movie of the remains of the
day I don't myself make a huge I don't
disagree with you but you know I I think
all the art forms have their special
powers you know sure there are things
that I can't do that the filmmakers can
do very very well and vice versa I just
go to you I can Frank because I know
that you are a writer you've written
short stories which have been published
and you have a novel which has been
unpublished about an astrophysicist at a
university that it might get published
now that you are a Nobel laureate
listening let him know thanks for the
plug well for me the English language
became a medium of reinventing myself
really I mean it was a very challenging
thing and and when I discovered it I
could write dialogue and got something
across there was an incredible
experience to me I'm I'm saying it's
sort of daunted by the idea I'm sitting
next to him laureate in literature and
talking about my little little
production well a small point about that
in sort of in the interest of young
scientists and which is I think a lot of
young scientists
don't pay any attention to the writing I
don't mean writing a novel well when you
do research the end product is something
written and until you've written it down
you haven't done anything that concerns
me as well you know very much but you
just say as somebody from the world of
the Arts there seems to be some sort of
disconnect with with your great
discoveries and your breakthroughs and
and then what the rest of society gets
preoccupied about and in popular culture
and popular debate it seems to me we the
world the Western world anyway is very
well prepared for a zombie attack on our
major cities but we don't seem to be
addressing you know how we reorganize
our societies as a result of some of the
staggering breakthroughs that are being
made in science and technology
one particular aspect of science which
really has captured the public
imagination popular imagination of
course is the world of science fiction I
come to the physics laureates because
you won your prize for the observation
of gravitational waves it was the first
time that a passing gravitational wave
has been observed directly on earth that
you know huge scientific sensations so
Kip Thorne why don't you just
encapsulate for us what this was all
about so a black hole is something that
every child knows from comic books but a
black hole is a spherical hole in space
that has such intense gravity that
nothing can get out not even light and
what we discovered was that 1.3 billion
years ago in a galaxy far far away two
black holes circled around and around
each other
spiraling together as they emitted these
gravitational waves losing energy to the
gravitational waves the holes came
crashing together at half the speed of
light and they created a veritable storm
in the shape of space and time time
slowed down then sped up ocellated while
if you can imagine time they're speeding
up and slowing down relative to how time
flows here and that process produced
these waves in which space is stretched
and squeezed stretched and squeezed that
travelled across interstellar space
intergalactic space to the earth and
were captured by the or monitored by the
instruments were built by the
experimental team that I am associated
with this is a whole new way to study
the universe to study aspects of the
universe that we've never seen before
it's a way by which we will in due
course watch the birth of the universe
and for the first time really come to
understand through a combination of this
with a theory the birth of the universe
ray and Barry I mean what kind of it's a
window on the world or on our universe
what kind of things might we discover
about our universe
that we don't know now Barry we've
worked for decades developing an
instrument much like we heard the
chemists talk about this just astounding
I mean I can't imagine that we could do
what we could do except that we learned
very early that you couldn't prove that
we couldn't do it so we kept making
steps and as I think Ray said earlier
people keep asking us how could we stay
at this so long persistence no it was
really a lot of fun because we've broken
new ground all the time
much as you have without maybe making a
discovery but just experimentally go
further than people have before black
holes of course really are very much the
stuff of science fiction films Kip
Thorne you a scientific adviser and
executive producer of one such film
interstellar how important is it for you
do you think that science fiction should
actually pays based on fact there's no
necessity there are different genres of
science fiction and my partner in
Hollywood Linda opes who together with
me wrote the treatment from which
interstellar spraying she calls this
science faction by contrast with science
fantasy Harry Potter is science fantasy
interstellar science faction but the
beauty of this for me is that a film
like this where the science is embedded
in right from the beginning it's capable
of inspiring people about science how
else could I as a professor succeed in
providing some inspiration for 100
million people except you feel like this
one one particular thing that you know a
lot of people sort of like to know about
in science fiction stories are there
other universes out there parallel
universes I mean could your work in any
way help us discover whether there are
indeed other universes Barry
well it might there's different we don't
if we had an easy and straightforward
test to see
there was this idea was right we'd
probably be going after it there's
various ways that we might get clues
whether it's right and some of them are
through the kind of work we're doing
it's not very direct it's one of the
ideas that kind of Springs from what we
don't know about the early universe so
discussing here you know the success of
films like interstellar and
science-fiction - contradictions there
you might say I mean how importance of
just thinking about this issue you know
in general terms do you think that
evidence based discourse is in our
societies today let me get a view from
all of you on this particular issue
perhaps you first Jeff or people don't
know much about science and technology
they you know electricity a miracle for
example day to day things that never
existed centuries ago and now we're
taking for granted the proper American
in the United States is not only
ignorant but is actively belligerently
pugnaciously ignorance are you sick I
refuse go away or I'm secular humanists
I say who thinks that there are these
irrational influences and that you will
seek the triumph of Reason in the face
of all this Michael Ross passion a lot
of this has to do with with educational
landscape we've seen circumstances most
starkly in the US but but in Western
Europe as well where politicians
ambitious people take advantage of the
situation to exploit for their own
benefit for power gain of power it's not
something that's unprecedented
happened in the 20th century to
disastrous to disastrous ends and so
it's it's it's a very worrisome it's
very worrisome concept Mike young you
can have an attitude that you're not
interested in science and you don't
can't benefit from science these
wouldn't exist if there hadn't been
discovered
50 years ago that invented the
technologies if you get just about every
minute of the day everyone depends on
some form of technology so that the
notion that it's over or we have enough
or it never happened or it never
happened that this is brand-new and
created from whole cloth is is such an
incredible mistake richard thaler we
have a fact free Administration in the
United States worrying about science it
would be nice if there was there were
scientists in the administration I would
settle for some people who are
collecting facts right but Barry it's
interesting we you know talk about we've
heard and science bias from from Jeff
Hall for instance but you're like oh
project for the observation of these
gravitational waves do you think that
kind of support would happen today for
something like we did yeah well I'm
worried not not you can't do science and
move forward without taking risks yet we
have a system that's become more and
more conservative I personally knowing
the funding situation pretty well in the
u.s. through the National Science
Foundation don't believe that right now
you could fund something that was
equivalent we as scientists have a job
it's not just that we we have a job to
make what we do more intelligible to
people I think that that's why I mean
Kip's movie is an important thing I
think you also have to go and talk to
people who are not at college levels you
have to talk to high school kids and
grade school kids yeah I agree
completely with with Ray on this and I
think the one key aspect I'd like to
emphasize is the importance that the
general public that the majority of the
populace in a democracy particularly
understands how science works
understands its powers its limitations
jacques de poche the remark by mister
ichigo ho that it would be easy
to develop and make great a story about
zombies coming on us and destroy
everything easy but why is it so
difficult why does it work to make a
terrible story about our climate going
astray
going about as bad as the zombie on
earth why can't we make a story of that
well you're working Frank we talked
before about the the difficulty of
getting science even across to the
public and that there are no existing
forums and you know the problem is we
have all these forums the media in the
media you know chop everything into
pieces and and people are completely
incapable of getting some kind of a
coherent story out of this Richard
Henderson do you think that the role of
the scientists is to explain their
science to society but also beyond that
to actually say we want to raise the
level of knowledge based comments and
debates I'm completely with with you on
that actually I think scientists are I
am an optimist about this whole
discussion I think scientists
particularly have to be optimists you
couldn't have worked for 50 years to to
look for gravitational waves without
being an optimist to differentiate
between rational irrational fact and
fiction better education I think is the
answer actually and lots of people want
better education for their children some
of them take their children out of
school to give them a better education
of home some people take them out of
school to avoid it exactly so we need to
improve the general to indoctrinate yeah
something better education is the bottom
line but what
it's
ish you have in the past 30 s I mean
you're sitting with scientists people
deal with facts but you're going to make
a plea for also fiction has a place in
in society obviously we like reading
works of fiction fiction culture I mean
I think one of the issues is that the
business model behind the media and
journalism and reporting is currently
broken the traditional ways in which
newspapers and periodicals used to
spread knowledge and debate and they
were rewarded for by-and-large for
accuracy is gone what is important at
the moment is that it is eyeballs you
know on websites clips you know that
there isn't a good economic economically
viable business model by which we can
have these debates because people are
driven by by the fact that you have to
get maximize the number of clicks on the
website right well I hope you have found
well I hope you'll make an honorable
exception of this program at least and
that you have had the chance to interact
with these great minds as well as adding
your great mind to our our debate here
our discussion I think everybody has
found in the audience and beyond
everything that you've said really
absolutely and fascinating I've
certainly enjoyed talking to all of you
thank you to all our Nobel laureates to
our audience here in Stockholm at the
concert hall from me Zainab Badawi and
all of this on the noble minds team
thank you very much indeed for watching
goodbye
[Music]
you